bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
aujourd'hui 26 novembre nous allons
revenir sur une situation sous tension
toujours dans les caisses d'allocations
familiales postes supprimés hausse des
demandes d'allocataires qui ont poussé
les syndicats à une grève nationale en
fin de semaine dernière
et quelle situation dans les yvelines
invité ce soir à lambert tout
représentant force ouvrière à la caf des
yvelines nous sommes lundi nous feront
aussi le point sur le sport le point sur
les sports avec anthony rech bonsoir en
tenez bon soir une bruine
au menu ce soir du 13 mai de nuit cette
fois avec le ver treille cette course
organisée par les élèves du lycée de
marie curie de versailles ce week-end
dans la forêt de porchefontaine au menu
par ailleurs du rugby avec le prc le
plaisir rugby club est sur le podium de
fédérale 3 et reste plus que jamais dans
la course pour les playoffs après la
phase aller du championnat et puis comme
d'habitude en fin de chronique
tous les résultats du week-end tous les
résultats à suivre aux alentours de
18h15 si vous nous suivez en direct et
puis à noter que ce soir nous
reviendrons aussi sur l'usagé du
téléphone au volant il se banalise la
prévention routière vient de lancer une
nouvelle campagne le responsable dans le
département sera également avec nous en
plateau il est 18 heures passées de
quelques minutes si vous nous suivez
donc en direct la suite de ce sommet du
26 novembre en images à présent une
nouvelle campagne pour les restos du
coeur la 28e déjà un reportage dans le
centre de distribution des yvelines aux
clayes-sous-bois là c'est là que sont
stockés les denrées alimentaires qui
approvisionne les 26 centres du
département
en 2012 plus d'un million de repas a été
servi
une nouvelle maison de covilha voisins
le bretonneux inauguré samedi soir un
travail mené par l'architecte fabien
duchêne coût des travaux 1,4 million
d'euros à ce sera à découvrir au cours
de cette édition
ils sont sept athlètes handisport avoir
intégré la section tennis de table du
club d'elancourt la section a été créée
il ya deux ans sous l'impulsion de
florent siro gossio la pongiste qui
vient de participer aux jeux
paralympiques de londres
et puis un club de bowling qui abat ses
quilles plus vite que son ombre le club
d'elancourt il compte une vingtaine de
membres les entraînements lieu à nos
repas c'est l'une des plus importantes
écoles de l'île de france
soixante mille bénévoles des restos se
mobilisent donc depuis ce matin pour
combattre la crise depuis trois ans le
nombre de bénéficiaires a progressé de
25% alors que les ressources restent
toujours menacés direction elle les
clayes-sous-bois avec johanna soudry et
elodie moigne pour faire un point sur
notre secteur du département des
yvelines
maurice glory est retraité et bénévole
aux restos du coeur depuis plus de deux
ans il s'occupe de l'entrepôt de
l'association basée aux clayes-sous-bois
l'année dernière l'équipe des bénévoles
à préparer 1400 palette pour
approvisionner des 26 centres que compte
le département des yvelines ont géré à
peu près 120 types d'articles pour la
distribution donc ça va surtout ce qui
est l'accompagnement classique les pâtes
le riz les concernent
après vous avez toute une série de
protides tout ce qui est conserves de
poissons tout ce qui est produit
surgelé vous avez après du dessert et
des produits laitiers
l'objectif des restos fournir aux
bénéficiaires un repas complet et
équilibré les besoins varieront selon
les centres les plus petits pourront
servir 120 repas par semaine tandis que
les plus importants en distribuerons
4000 l'entrepôt stop plus de 80% de
marchandises alimentaires
le reste se répartit entre produits
d'hygiène et d'entretien pour les bébés
couches lait de croissance et petits
pots destinés à près de 500 nourrisson
chaque semaine si la campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur vient juste de
débuter à l'entrepôt où on prépare déjà
les palettes pour la semaine suivante la
distribution comment ce matin et on est
parti pour officiellement cette semaine
mais traditionnellement on fait dix sept
semaines pour des marrants débuteront
début de campagne à 45 minimes
on finira plus de 60 pays dont le nombre
de bénéficiaires ne cesse de croître et
les bénévoles sont plus que jamais
recherché autre difficulté la
disparition du programme européen d'aidé
aux plus démunis
il s'en présente 20 à 25 % des
approvisionnements ici
donc si bout tellement ça disparaît je
pense qu'on n'a pas de solution
instantanée pour remplacer ça donc on
espère que les politiques seront
mobilisés pour maintenir ce budget
les salariés des caisses d'allocations
familiales en colère à travers la france
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
face à une somme une hausse des demandes
en raison de la situation économique et
de la crise bien sûr qui touche les
ménages elle des salariés qui étaient
donc en grève jeudi dernier par tout en
france ils étaient 38% à suivre le
mouvement dans le département alain
baert ou bonsoir donc responsable force
ouvrière pour la caf des yvelines
cette mobilisation dans le département
vous satisfait 38% on est dans la
moyenne nationale
je crois qu'effectivement on remercie de
leur sort déjà ce soir je crois que
effectivement la mobilisation dans les
yvelines est identique à peu près au
niveau national et une mobilisation sans
précédent
ça correspond à 38 % effectivement de la
moyenne des gens des collègues présents
mais représentent deux cent quatorze
collègues aussi qu'ils ont décidé à ce
moment là ce jour là à l'appel des
fédérations fo et cgt d'appeler à la
grève pour les raisons que vous venez
d'évoquer d'ailleurs et qui sont je
dirais l'appel du 22 novembre des
fédérations et fo et cgt un des points
culminants de ce qui se passe dans les
caves
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois sinon
plusieurs années au travers des rues
structuration des caf des suppressions
de postes qui ont été constatés la
première fois le 7 novembre par la
fédération il fo et cgt et par le
conseiller du ministre qui a reçu les
fédérations il faut à ce moment là et
qui a effectivement avalisé le fait que
en trois ans depuis les dernières
conventions d'objectifs et de gestion
plus de 1000 postes avaient été
supprimés à l'intention entre la caisse
nationale effectivement la caf et l'état
a conduit à la suppression de 1000
postes entre 2009 et 2012 ce à travers
la france ça concerne combien d'emplois
sur le secteur des mines sur le secteur
des yvelines c'est très difficile à
chiffrer parce que s'ils voulaient il ya
une évolution et des embauches tout en
ayant des suppressions de postes pour
réaliser ce qu'on appelle les
conventions d'objectifs et de gestion
qui sont ni plus ni moins que
le respect du traité de stabilité et des
réductions de coûts dans les services
publics donc à partir de là on comprend
bien que il faut passer par différentes
phases passe par des réductions
d'effectifs des restructurations
immobilières
la réduction systématique la recherche
systématique de réductions de coûts et
le personnel que ce soit dans la caf des
yvelines où ou dans d'autres cas il n'y
a pas eu une seule caf aujourd'hui au
niveau national qui épargnent et bach
par sept par cette situation a exprimé
son ras-le-bol et ça a été l'un des
premiers points culminants le 22
novembre qui a mené cette situation
forte mobilisation jusqu'à 38 % de
grévistes dans ce département des
yvelines
concrètement quelles sont les
difficultés que vous rencontrez avec ces
suppressions de postes milles à travers
la france on le disait tout à l'heure ça
se traduit comment des délais pour
traiter les dossiers qui sont plus longs
des files d'attentes aussi qui s'allonge
tout à fait don pire des situations
particulières puisque chaque caf à son
organisation
mais au travers de chaque organisation
le point le point central c'est les
suppressions d'effectifs c'est générale
dans toutes les caf pour ça que mes il
au niveau national ça paraît peu mais
c'est toujours le turnover est toujours
des postes qui sont supprimés de façon
distincte est différente dans les
différents départements
que ce soit la région parisienne au
niveau national et ont leurs effets
importants au niveau social vous me
disiez en préalable puisque par exemple
la caf des yvelines
gr plus d'un milliard d'euros de
prestations d'accord deux cent dix mille
familles allocataires qui concernent et
qui impacte surtout 331 milles enfants
et qui ont un impact social de plus en
plus important compte tenu de la montée
de la précarité et de la pauvreté et du
chômage ainsi tweed et les caf
aujourd'hui que soit la caf des yvelines
où les autres ont plus les moyens
aujourd'hui d'assurer je veux dire à un
service public de qualité
alors ça prend différentes formes on a
cherché dans les yvelines à rationaliser
en fermant les accueille tous les après
midis depuis plus d'un an maintenant sa
part produit d'effet puisque aujourd'hui
alors les chiffres varient d'un mois sur
l'eau parce que l'un des systèmes qui
font que les vases communicants foo kune
caf nous aide
conley d'une cave pendant qu'on est en
retard c'est aberrant mais c'est comme
ça pour l'instant vous fermé
l'après-midi pour rattraper un petit peu
le retard sur les sur les deux forces
armées depuis début 2011 et sa pas
produit d'effet puisque aujourd'hui à
tant de retard est toujours à plus de 10
jours onze jours de retard
ce qui amène d'ailleurs les directions
la nôtre notamment au départ a demandé à
faire des heures supplémentaires le
samedi matin et comme ça suffit pas
maintenant généralisé du lundi au
vendredi vous voyez que on marche à
l'envers
alors c'est par l'addition de la
direction en tant que tel puisque c'est
un problème national mais aujourd'hui on
est dans cette situation ont demandé
ainsi de faire des heures
supplémentaires du lundi au vendredi
puisque le samedi plus après on sait pas
comme ça sert et salariés en raison de
noms des sociétés de création de postes
les hausses de demande de la part des
allocataires et donc on en vient des
situations la caisse d'allocations
familiales dont département des yvelines
toutes les antennes sont fermés l'après
midi pour permettre de rattraper le
retard et que vous venez de me dire
toujours jusqu'à dix jours de retard
pour instruire un dossier qui l'aurait
la moyenne nationale c'est au tour de
sept jours à peu près celle ci très
variable c'est très variable ya des caf
qui ont pas de retard il ya des cavs sur
plus de retard que la caf des divines
la caf des yvelines dont vous traitez
vous avez combien de familles sont
concernées par les prestations de la caf
dans le département deux cent dix mille
200 219 milliards de la terre et on
verse plus d'un milliard d'euros de
prestations et quand je lis prestation
c'est pas les prestations simplement de
précarité c'est toutes les prestations
et de logement allocations familiales et
qui sont aujourd'hui plus que nécessaire
puisque par exemple dans le bassin
mantois notamment qu'ils ont le sensible
il est sensible on s'aperçoit que là il
ya pratiquement plus de 20 % des
familles du bassin d'emploi qui ont
comme revenu de substitution les
allocations familiales telles les
prestations familiales
donc on est véritablement un amortisseur
social et on n'a plus les moyens
aujourd'hui véritablement d'assurer ce
service public
c'est pour ça que les revendications
qu'on dépose et les fédérations avec les
collègues
le 7 novembre le 22 novembre qui
continueront après c'est ce qu'a indiqué
notre secrétaire fédéral à la conférence
des présidents à marseille on
n'acceptera plus aujourd'hui pour les
allocataires et pour le personnel
aujourd'hui d'aller dans cette
dans cette perspective puisque sans
aller trop loin on a par rapport à la
préparation des prochaines conventions
d'objectifs et de gestion un rapport de
l'igas qui prévoit de supprimer encore
2000 postes non pour vous on arrête les
suppressions de postes c'est ce que vous
demandez avec les différents syndicats
notamment force ouvrière à vous demander
en plus des embauches merci à toi je
rappelle aussi le retard qui est
accumulée sur la seule solution
aujourd'hui pour force ouvrière des
embauches en panne il embauche par
exemple
je ferme en cdi par des embauches en
contrats précaires parce que ça réglait
pas le problème ni pour les agents qui
sans broncher nil pour la situation
puisque 120 vitraux dont plus en détail
il faut pratiquement un an un an et demi
pour former un technicien d'accord et
donc dans cette situation c'est aussi
l'arrêt des restructurations puisqu'ils
un projet aussi aujourd'hui à laquelle
des yvelines notamment qui qui prévoit
d'ici donc à 2016 avec un projet qui
n'est pas encore bouclé de fermer aussi
certaines antennes on vire trappe
conflent sartrouville et migros à 7,8
pour pour rationaliser aussi toujours
pas les activités liées au secteur de
saint-quentin exactement tout à fait
alors aujourd'hui juste sur les
conditions véritablement d'accueil pour
les allocataires qui viennent se rentrer
se rendre uniquement le matin maintenant
puisque saint germé donc l'après midi
l'attenté longue difficile comment se
passent aussi l'accueil est ce que pour
le personnel même de la caf il et il est
difficile quelquefois d'avoir à gérer
aussi les allocataires qui peuvent au
bout d'un moment on avoir marre
d'attendre d'avoir marre d'attendre
aussi leur dossier soit traité par
exemple est sûre non j'attends
effectivement leur idéal et variées
aussi par rapport au site
parce que bon il ya des figures plus ou
moins d'attenté attendre se focalise
dans les endroits effectivement
sensibles comme mantes la jolie
plus particulièrement où là avec hell
bourg l'événement qui a eu au mois
d'août il eu des mesures particulières
sur cet événement où il ya un
allocataire qui s'était effectivement
immolé dans l'une des caf du département
des yvelines puisqu'il n'avait plus
accès à ces à ces allocations
il n'avait plus accès à ces allocations
et il y avait aussi des conditions qui
faisaient que bon personnellement enfin
bon papa rentrer dans le détail
aujourd'hui mais je dirais qu'il ya des
mesures particulières qui se complaît
dans les prises en amont bertinotti est
venu à la cave de nantes
tout comme elle est intervenue la
conférence des présidents
puisqu'on veut aujourd'hui c'est pas des
mesurettes entre guillemets sévérité des
vraies mesures qui permettent à l'avenir
de rendre le service aux allocataires
on peut pas aujourd'hui nous en tant que
professionnel moi ça fait 34 ans que je
travaille à la caf des yvelines
je rentre à 18 ans on peut pas
aujourd'hui on voit la dégradation des
conditions alors elle est pas tout dit
dans les yvelines aussi importante que
dans d'autres départements comme le 93
mais n'empêche que ya pas une caf
aujourd'hui qui échappent à ces mesures
qui à la restriction est impressionnant
les cinq départements d emilie toujours
depuis 34 eur et en 34 ans la situation
s'est dégradée progressivement
régulièrement progressivement j'irai
progrès ces dernières années elle c'est
pour ça qu'il s'accélère s'accélère elle
s'accélère oui parce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui que y avait des prestations
comme le rmi le rsa l'allocation adulte
handicapé et tout c'est des prestations
dignes de précarité mais aujourd'hui on
voit que pour beaucoup d'allocataires
même les simples prestations familiales
genre une prestation de garde ou ou
allocations familiales ou allocations
logement et si ce que disait un collègue
de dunkerque de cergy a pas très
longtemps même des prestations qui avant
était le traditionnel sont aujourd'hui
des revenus de substitution accord une
aide au logement aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'allocataires qui même avec
des revenus sont en difficulté pour
payer leur loyer et donc même déposé des
dossiers pour lesquels on leur a indiqué
qu'il n'avait pas le droit mais il le
dépose donc ça fait une surcharge de
travail aussi il faut que ça rentre en
compte dans la difficulté à gérer je
dirais les prestations aujourd'hui par
rapport aussi à la responsabilité qu'on
a quand effectivement on reçoit un
allocataire comme moi j'étais je vais
faire je suis toujours un genre
d'accueil je détache et aux syndicats
mais j'étais agent d'accueil et on voit
quelques fois la détresse des des
allocataires qui savent pas comment
exprimer
comment exprimer le fait qu'ils savent
pas comment faire et finir les finir le
mois alors que derrière vous avez de
moins en moins de temps pour justement
pour pour échanger pour discuter avec
ses allocataires tout à fait complet
présente d'accélération d'accidents dans
ce dossier
les suppressions de postes alors vous
demander effectivement l'arrêt des
suppressions de poste vous demandez
également forcément des embauches on
nous l'avait dit d embauche en cdi
la grève a été suivie dans le
département des yvelines 38 % des
salariés de la caf qui est qu'ils
étaient en grève jeudi dernier est ce
que vous avez été entendu ce que vous
avez eu des réponses de la direction des
insignes du gouvernement des choses qui
vous laissent à penser que ça a servi à
quelque chose
alors pour l'instant c'est prématuré
puisque cette grève est lui le jour de
la conférence des présidents à marseille
donc notre secrétaire fédéral est
intervenue à ce moment là et pour
l'instant on peut venez pas eu de compte
rendu de cette réunion des conférences
des présidents mais j'ai eu tout à
l'heure je n'ai pas encore eu le temps
de lire puisque j'ai vu cet après midi à
jules le discours de madame bertinotti
la secrétaire d'état chargée de la
famille qui semble pas aller dans le
sens de part de la satisfaction des
revendications mais tout simplement dans
dans le sens de notamment la petite
enfance sont des choses comme ça donc on
verra cette semaine un petit peu comment
dans un accident éventuellement vous ai
pensé notre mouvement de grève pour
cours l'os pour l'instant si vous voulez
c'est compliqué au niveau national de
dire aujourd'hui ce soir ça va
généraliser où ça va pas généraliser il
faut que ça que chaque caf aujourd'hui
face ne compte qu'un petit peu de la
situation dans laquelle il est tant au
niveau des prestations que de l'accueil
et ainsi de suite
et puis envisager effectivement d'autres
mouvements peut-être locaux ou nationaux
aussi les fédérations tire le bilan de
la première réunion le 7 novembre
puisque ça a commencé le 7 novembre avec
les fédérations fo cgt qui ont été reçus
combien certaines informations et qui
ont appelé le 22
qui donc pour la fédérations fo et cgt
je dirais tiendront tiendront compte de
cette mobilisation moi je dirais sans
aller trop loin sans précédent dans les
caf vocation à hauteur de 38 % dans le
département des yvelines
on en parlait tout à l'heure c'était
jeudi dernier et puis cette situation
qui reste un sous tension dans les
différentes caf avec un nombre de
dossiers à traiter qui augmente et puis
un temps réduit nous
il avait expliqué pour pour les agents
tout simplement pour instruire ces
différents dossiers jusqu'à dix jours de
retard pour que les dossiers soient soit
instruit merci d'être venu donc sur ce
plateau alain berteaux de le force
ouvrière la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines dans un instant
la chroniqueuse sport d'anthony rêche et
puis il ya tout à l'heure nous
reviendrons aussi sur la campagne menée
par la prévention routière contre
l'usagé du téléphone au volant 10% des
accidents corporels sont liés à cette
mauvaise habitude des usagers de la
route pour l'instant une nouvelle maison
de covilha voisins le bretonneux
inaugurait à ce samedi soir un travail
mené par l'architecte fabien duchêne
coût des travaux 1,4 million d'euros
la maison de co villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux comme neuve
totalement transformé l'espace culturel
a ouvert ses portes ce week end pour une
inauguration en son et lumière une
entrée redessiné un lieux inondés de
lumière et des accès que tous peuvent
emprunter
tel est le nouveau visage du centre
culturel de voisins-le-bretonneux avant
l'escalier ne permettait pas à tout le
monde de pouvoir accéder aux salles
d'exposition
c'est une
maison je pense plus accueillante et une
maison qui permettra d'avoir des
spectacles vivants avec ce grand parvis
que nous avons fait de vendre la maison
les architectes roberto sirianni et
fabien duchêne ont pensé modernité tout
en conservant l'âme et la mémoire d'une
bâtisse historique comme toutes les
vieilles maisons il ya beaucoup de
massivité c'était beau produit des bons
matériaux mais on a du mal à faire
fonctionner programme contemporain on a
vu un magnifique place devant on a vu
qu'avec quelques arbres à l'arrière
s'est dit bon quelque chose à jouer
entre devant derrière on s'est dit aussi
que cette maison ont circulé malotaux
donc on a failli sur un jardin et donc
du coup ils devenus une espèce de
d'éléments de centrales
le coeur du bâtiment a été détruit pour
laisser place à la lumière et la
transparence
les gens se voient les uns avec les
autres et donc du coup ils visualisent
mais l'espace ça qu'on peut très bien
avoir quelques rites et on est rentré
qu'un état différent
c'est ce qu'ont cherché leur
modernisation mise aux normes de
sécurité création d'un ascenseur mais
aussi loges supplémentaires en sous-sol
bureaux locaux associatifs
la nouvelle maison de coville était une
priorité pour la municipalité qui a pris
en charge la moitié du coût des travaux
dont le total s'élève à 1 million 400
mille euros